amantha starts off this hour in las
vegas hi Amanda welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave thank you for taking
my call sir
sure what's up so my fit my question is
me and my husband we were with my
grandmother she's elderly concern to get
dementia and we moved in with her
because we needed help with our dead and
things like that so now we want to move
out and the thing is as we move out be
paying
repaints 625 now in France so the place
we're looking that would be 1,200 a
month in rent and we just got the Total
Money Makeover book so we're trying to
do better and trying to have a plan with
feeling whatever debt so we're just
wondering if it's we should move out now
the reason we're thinking of moving out
is because she is getting older and my
parents would be the ones to move in
with her and they want to they do they
don't have a place of their own they're
currently staying with friends and their
forms are these degrees
you don't they aren't really good with
money being my mom my mom had always
been the sole provider she doesn't have
a job and my dad gets military benefits
that equaled for about 625 so that's all
they're losing on okay holding their
parents they are 5856 okay so how much
debt do you guys have we have about
seventy four thousand and dot what's
your helpful near them the household is
revenue 3000 your your household income
seventy three thousand you have $70,000
in debt yeah okay and we're talking
about $1,200
rent yeah
that's a little steep okay
how many kids are doing we have no kids
just me and my husband that's definitely
a little steep like you need to look for
a rental because you need to get out of
that but it sounds like you're moving
yeah I mean if you don't move what
happens your parents don't have a place
to live and your grandmother I mean not
necessarily my husband was saying if we
don't move and we stay we can pay our
debt off faster and my parents will just
have to figure it out
my mom does come in for the house whites
our condo every day to check why my
grandmother because me my husband are at
work so like that would continue she
would still be checked up let's just say
right now you're paying six and a
quarter and you're providing care in the
evenings for your grandmother right yeah
okay so let's say that you moved and not
to 1200 but you move to something that
was nine and a quarter okay
that's $300 that's $3,600 a year
difference that's not spit against 70
grand what moves the needle on 70 grand
did you guys work an extra jobs because
you don't have to take care of your
grandmother and what moves the needle is
you guys tighten your budget and really
really really making your 73000 work
much harder towards this debt $3,600 a
year is not getting you out of debt on
$70,000 worth of debt unless you want to
be in debt for 25 years yeah so your
husband's math is wrong okay it's just a
minimal amount I mean if you were saving
$25,000 a year by living there well now
we can talk about it but you're saving
$3,000 a year by living there right so
get you something under $1,000 to rent
and pick up two extra jobs while Geezer
since you don't have to take care of
grandmother at night let your parents
take care of your grandmother which is
what they want to do anyway and you're
going to get out of that even faster
that's what is that's what the net
results going to be